in early October one of Haiti's largest
companies made a startling announcement
due to insufficient supplies it could no
longer produce water
without clean water the country soon
became victim to an outbreak of Cholera
and although the disease is both
preventable and treatable Haiti's
Capital Porto Prince population nearly 1
million was down to just three working
ambulances
yet neither a lack of Clean Water a
deadly outbreak of Cholera nor even an
acute shortage of Medical Care topped
the list of Haiti's most pressing
challenges
these are merely three symptoms of a
much bigger problem a chronic fuel
shortage causing prices to climb as high
as fifty dollars a gallon
without fuel ambulances couldn't respond
to emergencies children couldn't get to
school and electricity was unavailable
even to homes fortunate enough to have
it
many companies couldn't even pay their
workers effectively pressing pause on
civilization
the fuel shortage was caused by the
blockade of a storage site responsible
for 70 percent of the nation's oil by an
armed Coalition of gangs
the same gangs who regularly terrorize
the population carrying out violence in
broad daylight often in view of police
unfortunately this is nothing new
in Haiti it's often difficult to discern
where one crisis ends and another begins
articles from years past could almost be
reprinted word for word today
this one from 2019 perfectly describes
the most recent crisis
and these two written over a decade
apart sound eerily similar
stories of one or another disaster in
Haiti have become an almost routine
feature of the news cycle along with
North Korean missile tests and Facebook
privacy scandals
just last year it was hit with a
magnitude 7.2 earthquake killing
thousands and doing 10 of the entire
national GDP in damage
Haiti's president was assassinated just
38 days earlier
and only 67 miles away from this most
recent earthquake was the epicenter of
another in 2010.
that one killed at least 160 000 people
and destroyed some of its most historic
buildings
the result has been Decades of economic
stagnation
this is the average GDP in the Latin
America and Caribbean region its
neighbors
these are all low-income countries
and this meanwhile is Haiti
40 of the population 4.4 million people
need urgent humanitarian assistance
now there's no doubt geography plays a
role the island sits in an earthquake
Hot Spot within a hot spot and
hurricanes are a fact of life
the data is unambiguous natural
disasters occur more frequently do more
damage and are more fatal in Haiti
compared to its neighbors
but what all these things have in common
from its inability to recover from
natural disasters to the fact that gangs
can effectively hijack the entire
country is a lack of State capacity
the government is weak overwhelmed and
frequently short-lived
in the three and a half decades between
1986 and 2021 for instance the average
president served for just one year and
11 months
in that time only two served their full
five-year terms one lasted just three
days and seven of these 19 presidents
held office for less than a year
political instability is by far the
country's number one barrier to
development
the question is if political instability
is the root of Haiti's problems what's
the root of this instability
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
for a limited time right now for the
holidays you can get both for an amazing
11.59 a year and start watching my
exclusive series China actually
when the 13 colonies declared
independence in 1776 the United States
was overshadowed economically by one of
its tiny Southern neighbors Haiti
then a French Colony Haiti was the
source of 75 of the world sugar and half
of its coffee despite being roughly the
size of Massachusetts
it was in fact the richest colony in the
new world though of course this immense
wealth did not reach the almost million
slaves who at one point or another were
brought there
but what many of their French colonizers
didn't realize is that many of these
slaves were former soldiers captured in
battle throughout central Africa
and when the French Revolution reached
the shores of Haiti in 1791 they rose up
declaring the First Independent
Caribbean States and first free black
Republic
to symbolize this the Republic's first
flag was based on France's with a white
stripe removed
there was however one major problem
a bit of small print that would haunt
the country for centuries to come
although Haiti had triumphed in battle
against the French Spanish English and
even Napoleon himself there was one
thing it still needed recognition
for France losing control of its most
profitable colony was a national
embarrassment
for years it refused even to speak the
name Haiti pretending as if nothing ever
happened
but without recognition Haiti was
effectively stuck in limbo unable to
sign treaties send diplomats or feel
secure in its sovereignty
so having exhausted all other options
Haiti's president made a suggestion what
if it could simply pay
for years the two countries negotiated
back and forth until one day France
decided enough was enough
Haiti would owe it 112 million francs
about 560 million in today's dollars
French Goods would be subject to only
half the standard tariffs and in return
it would finally recognize the country's
existence
but this time it wasn't asking
if Haiti refused it threatened to
bombard the capital with cannon fire
Haiti had no choice
while many empires have been called on
to pay reparations only in Haiti did
slaves pay their former Masters forced
essentially to buy their own bodies
France didn't just deal much needed
resources from this newly independent
republic
resources it used to build the Eiffel
Tower
it also trapped the country in a Payday
loan-like cycle of debt
it had no choice but to take on more and
more loans often with predatory interest
rates and fees
in 1838 half of Haiti's annual budget
was spent on the military less than one
percent on education and about 30
percent servicing its national debt
by the turn of the century that 30
percent had become 50 and in 1914 a
staggering 80 percent
it's been estimated that without this
debt the nation's per capita income
might be six times higher today
and yet even this steep sacrifice did
not earn Haiti a seat at the
international table
more than 50 years after it declared
independence two important Powers still
refused to recognize it the Vatican and
the United States
to do so places like America and Britain
thought might Inspire similar revolts
among slaves at home
only in 1862 after Southern States left
the union did the U.S officially
recognize it
little did Haiti know American
involvement would soon become much more
a curse than a blessing
between 1870 and 1905 the share of U.S
Imports to Haiti nearly doubled from
less than 40 percent to over 70. the
former French Colony effectively freed
itself from the grips of one Empire only
to replace it with another and this new
one was no less greedy
from Washington's point of view Haiti
was becoming far too dominated by German
Merchants who weren't afraid to use
their wealth to support Revolution
on the eve of World War One Americans
weren't too keen on inviting the Germans
into their backyard
they also had an interest in opening up
Haiti's economy which as a safeguard
against a return to slavery was largely
off limits to foreigners
in reality the Germans likely had no
intention of taking over Haiti but it
didn't matter the United States saw its
golden opportunity to kill two birds
with one stone to drive out the Germans
while converting a perennial source of
instability just 600 miles from Florida
into an obedient client state
the U.S government at the time didn't
actually know much about Haiti but it
soon found an ally more than happy to
fill its vacuum of knowledge Wall Street
two American corporations Haiti
represented a giant untapped Market if
only it were stable
the only thing that could stabilize it
they decided was U.S occupation and the
only thing that could compel a U.S
occupation was an acute crisis
so they set out to create one
the National City Bank of New York now
known as Citibank set its plan in motion
by purchasing a majority stake in a
Haitian bank but not just any ordinary
Bank
as a private for-profit French
Corporation it could simply be bought
but it also just so happened to serve as
Haiti's National treasury with a
monopoly on printing currency holding
tax revenue and even commercial lending
Services it provided to the government
for a fee
whoever owned it in other words
effectively owned Haiti
all the Americans had to do to get what
they wanted was withhold the
government's money or just outright
steal it and that's exactly what they
did
their opportunity came after another
investor James McDonald promised to
build a railway connecting two of
Haiti's largest cities
in exchange he was granted the rights to
12 miles of land on each side of the
tracks where he planned on building
banana plantations
to locals this sounded suspiciously like
a return to the exact kind of
foreign-owned export economy the country
was founded to prevent
these alarm Bells led to an uprising and
seven presidents came and went in a
matter of just four years
although this was far from the most
violence Haiti had ever seen this time
American property was at risk providing
the perfect pretext for an invasion
in 1914 U.S Marines landed in Porto
Prince stole millions of dollars in gold
from the national Treasury and sailed
away as if they hadn't just committed
17th century armed piracy
a year later they returned this time
they stayed for nearly two decades
during which the U.S installed a puppet
government declared martial law and
re-established a form of forced labor
beating out the French for the title of
Haiti's biggest villain was a near
impossible task but the Americans
somehow managed
[Music]
far from stabilizing the country laying
the groundwork for Rapid Economic
Development as intended U.S involvement
had an unexpected consequence
not only did it centralize power and
help normalize political violence but it
also undermined the government's
legitimacy
how could Haitians see their leaders as
being legitimate when they answered
first to Washington
now to be clear the Haitian government
has historically been just as much a
perpetrator as a victim of this broken
system
corruption is rampant and violence at
best tolerated and all too often
outright state-sponsored
nobody in or outside of Haiti trusts its
government and for good reason
but this creates its own problems
take for example the devastating 2010
earthquake
unlike most foreign natural disasters it
not only captured but sustained the
world's attention
Millions donated to relief efforts and
2.29 billion dollars in Aid was promised
in total
suddenly Haiti was being overwhelmed
with money and for once genuine Goodwill
the only question was where to put it
when the earthquake struck the
government of Haiti was so weak that U.N
peacekeepers were already in the country
on a different Mission it not only wiped
out virtually every public building but
also the very U.N building which would
have provided earthquake relief
just one percent of humanitarian Aid and
23 percent of recovery funds between
2010 and 11 were directed to the
government
instead nearly every last penny went as
it always does in Haiti to ngos
and as more and more money bypasses the
government it becomes weaker and weaker
ensuring the next Crisis is even
deadlier
it's clear that Haiti will never escape
this cycle until it has strong capable
and competent leadership
but it's also become abundantly clear
that foreign intervention is more likely
to aggravate than relieve Haiti's
suffering
that although the source of its
challenges may be foreign The Cure can't
be
that although geography May predispose
the country to frequent natural
disasters the Haiti of 2022 was far from
predetermined
natural explanations for Haiti's
struggles are simply an excuse for
centuries of abuse by foreign powers the
same storm after all can be catastrophic
in one place and only mildly
inconvenient in another
and the scientific reasons for that are
actually quite interesting this weekend
I'm watching countdown to a catastrophe
storms on today's sponsor curiosity
stream home to thousands of great
documentaries on History Science and
nature
right now for a limited time during the
holidays you can get curiosity stream
and nebula together 42 off for just
11.59 a year on nebula you can watch my
exclusive original series China actually
including the episode I just released
last week explaining why China has a
surprisingly responsible nuclear posture
and why that matters
at less than a dollar a month for two
streaming platforms you won't find a
better deal
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream and
start watching today